mid-afternoon at an outlet mall in Texas
and a horror all too common here is
about to begin
watch the man step out of a silver car
and start shooting people on the
pavement and listen to how quickly it
happens
a handgun or a pistol it's a weapon of
War at a shopping mall
people here know what they're running
from some have heard the sounds before
we see the guy there's this guy dressing
all black wearing a vest has an assault
rifle and he's just shooting at people
right across he was at like Francesca's
area shooting at people so we got
everyone in the store in the back of the
store and just camped out there
while somebody got shot and ran in and
she was crouching in the front and I
went to grab her and they shot through
the door and then we just took her to
the back there was that people on the
floor a lot of people they were like you
know hiding and as I was going around
they told me to get away you know to
move out and I kept on telling them I'm
looking for my daughter people were
evacuated from their hiding places by
police in Allen just north of Dallas the
gunman was killed by an officer who
happened to be nearby the motive is
still unknown at 3 36 our officer was at
Allen Premium Outlets on an unrelated
call
he heard gunshots located The Gunshot
located the shooter neutralized the
shooter neutralized the threat we
believe at this point that the shooter
acted alone barely a week ago a man in
Cleveland Texas killed five of his
neighbors who had complained about him
shooting in the back Garden most adults
here are allowed to carry a handgun
without a license and there was little
indication that might be about to change
we are a strong and caring community and
we all want the victims and their
families impacted by this tragedy to
know that we will wrap our arms around
you and we are here for you it's
difficult to compute but this is the
199th mass shooting in the United States
this year that has left four or more
people dead or wounded
dozens more families now torn apart by
The Familiar scourge of gun violence
Martha Kellner Sky News